[Music]
we're gonna get started to stay on
schedule thank you very much for coming
here this afternoon hopefully everyone's
had a successful productive conference
had a lot of interesting conversations
over the past week myself I'm Miles
vetro I'm a solutions architect with
Google came into Google with orbit era
and we're here to talk actually about
orbit era and a pudgy two recent
acquisitions by Google Cloud both of
which are multi cloud solutions
connected platforms meant to really
enable partner commerce across clouds
across different ecosystems across
different SAS platforms and really
trying to reduce friction and increase
adoption of partner solutions in the
cloud today so as we go through the
presentation today we have an agenda
we'll talk a little bit about the market
evolution of cloud and what the
implications of that are for ifvs talk a
little bit about the orbit our platform
speak to the apogee platform as well
talk about both of their functionalities
and real purposes and cloud commerce and
then talk about that joint value
proposition how orbiter and Apogee
jointly together can help accelerate
monetization of different kinds of
consumption and subscription based
products in multiple cloud environments
and then we're very fortunate to be
joined today by two mutual partners of
orbit area and a pudgy we have some
people from pitney bowes as well as from
veritas we're going to go through a
pitney bowes use case in demo showing
the potential of an end-to-end
customer-facing implementation of a
joint orbit era Apogee solution and then
we'll bring up a few of the members of
those companies on stage and have some
Q&A so let's go right into the market
evolution what does it mean when ISPs
have to go into the cloud
there's some really important
implications and it's much more
difficult than making sure that your
application just runs on cloud XYZ from
the ISDN side of things there's more
demands for the sales motion from their
customers customers and consumers in the
cloud are demanding more retail consumer
like experiences because quite frankly
enterprises don't care about what's
actually making the solution run they
just want to have it work pricing models
do to that sort of consumer focus that
the cloud is bringing are moving more
towards consumption based models pay by
the SIP rather than pay by the drink
we're also seeing that making sure that
is V systems can handle the new
monetization and pricing models in the
cloud can be difficult and users are
really adopting cloud marketplaces to
browse different kinds of solutions
discover solutions you probably heard a
lot this week about different kinds of
marketplace venues that are out there to
help make your your products
discoverable and it's not sufficient
anymore to only make yourself available
in one venue one infrastructure provider
even on the dev side we also see that
the actual depth process is impacted by
this whether you're trying to package
solutions into the cloud or you need
cloud-based building blocks to create
your solution if you use that old
enterprise procurement model where it's
not instant non demand it can elongate
your entire development cycle and
elongate your go-to-market activities it
also can restrict your developers from
using the most innovative and modern
products so having that click to
purchase brings back agility and having
consumption based pricing helps lower
costs and this should overall if we set
all these systems up correctly
help to make sure that devs are not
hindered by the inability to adapt to
quick new emerging technologies now the
marketplace writ large I mean everyone
here you're on day three of Google next
I don't need to convince you that the
cloud is someplace to be we all know
that the cloud is growing but it has
some very important implications about
where software sales models and where
stacks are going to be deployed in the
future so in 2019 according to this
research study about a third of all
enterprise applications will be cloud
only rather than cloud first cloud first
is still a big move today the industry
is evolving extremely rapidly
eighty-three percent of IT buyers rely
on product demos unless they want that
consumer driven cloud experience and
they want to get their hands dirty with
the solution before they're willing to
actually go to all of the time to
architect their end-to-end operational
workflow behind this cloud adoption and
when they get those demos they're fifty
percent more likely to actually adopt a
solution the industry is growing as well
these grey bars in the right-hand chart
are showing infrastructure spending
growth on the cloud what's not often
discussed is those blue bars that's
actual software spent on the cloud
specifically SAS and passed based
offerings most of which have to have
some kind of consumption based pricing
model behind them that software side of
the curve lower than infrastructure but
it's still expected to triple over the
next five years this is a massive
opportunity for isps today so what does
this mean well means if you're not a
cloud is V you're being disrupted by
your competition right now plain and
simple ifes have to adapt to the needs
of their customers
also in the cloud a lot of channel or
ecosystems have been left behind in the
direct marketplace model and ecosystems
that create network effects of multiple
partners creating multiple solutions are
where you can get true value and start
to drive more partner activity as well
as more end customer activities it's a
very virtuous self-fulfilling cycle in
order to create this ecosystem you have
to automate it any kind of manual
process and cloud distribution slows
things down a lot it's unnecessary
friction so both Apogee and orbit era
are really about enabling automation
enabling end-to-end integration to
create ecosystems that create virtuous
cycles of customer satisfaction and
partner engagement so let's talk a
little bit about orbit era as a product
I heard I heard a product manager from
one of our partners earlier today and he
said that orbiter has been talked about
quite a bit over the course of the week
not entirely sure what it does but it
seems like if you sprinkle a little
orbiter on it will solve your billing
problems so let's actually dig into what
orbit era is orbit era is an e-commerce
platform we try to bring entities on the
left who are our customers and this can
be software vendors it can be
distributors or resellers system
integrators that need different building
blocks to be combined into bundled
solutions or managed service providers
that like to layer on their own services
on top of cloud solutions all of these
are different customer types that can be
enabled with the orbit our platform and
with that network effect or the
ecosystem where orbit era can create
what we call an n-tier hierarchy we can
scale an unlimited number of tears down
sideways up
and this allows for flexible business
models and we try to bring those
entities on the right to their customers
we're sorry but the entities on the left
to their customers on their right and
those customers on the right might not
be the end user from a nice v's
perspective or distributors perspective
the reseller of the product is their
customer so they need to enable their
customer from that perspective to have a
more satisfying selling and development
experience so the middle of the box is
really talking about the different
orbital platform features the first row
is really our guiding principles where
we want to reduce friction we want to
package and provision different kinds of
software cloud providers access to
different cloud providers through native
cloud automation whenever possible
enabling single click deployment and
with a whole host of configurable
workflows to help you scale your
business to the next billion users the
next three rows talk about the different
product lines underlying orbit era and
you can think of these either a la carte
or holistically and we have some
partners who use orbitz arab mostly as a
billing engine some who use us for test
drive some as a white-label marketplace
but they can also be used holistically
so billing allows us to implement
subscription or consumption based
filling anytime we can get programmatic
access to that subscription or
consumption information we have native
support for gcp as well as for AWS for
Microsoft Azure for IBM SoftLayer for
centurylink cloud more than a dozen SAS
applications we can consume any kind of
metering or consumption stream and then
through our price books apply custom
pricing to either resellers or end-users
and wrapped around this is dashboards
reconciliation rope and reporting tools
that allow you to surface to your
customers a single pane of glass
through which they can consume their AWS
their gcp there a shiur their software
their SAS subscriptions everything in
one shop and we can deploy into multiple
cloud environments from that one
marketplace that leads us to the next
row marketplaces and catalogs where we
can enable our partners to create their
own e-commerce white labeled storefront
looks and feels like their domain
registered on their domain space and
hooked up with all of the consumption
and subscription pricing that's enabled
by the subscription management engine
underlying orbit era and all of this
again is an n-tier hierarchy an n-tier
architecture so we can enable your
channel partners to stand up their own
white label marketplaces where they
don't need to worry about the underlying
technical integrations lastly we have
trials and lead management also known as
test drive and this solution as well as
being integrated into multiple different
Google programs and is also available on
other clouds the thin line wrapping this
whole diagram is speaking to orbit areas
automation capabilities we want to
reduce friction not increase systems
complexity so we have a rich framework
of callbacks and ap is to automate
integrations with different kinds of
systems and ideally that end system is
something like apogee which is a unified
management platform that provides us a
single integration point to then speak
to all of the underlying systems within
an IFV I'll get into that in just a
minute so how does orbit hire help we
try to help you grow revenue accelerate
sales and optimize operations
specifically we help you grow revenue by
enabling true multi-cloud commerce when
I say that I mean that we actually meter
and deploy into multiple clouds we have
the big three public clouds today Google
cloud AWS and Azure
and we can bundle multiple
infrastructure as well as SAS or license
based solutions into a single product
that's deployed through that single
click framework and we do that through
the native provisioning services of
these different clouds it also helps
simplify the purchase experience because
it's a much more consumer driven kind of
feel and workflow and through this you
can actually customize consumption
pricing for any end-user it does not
have to be shared across users also we
have an able channel through that
multi-tier framework where every
reseller can have their own shingle
their own white label marketplace they
can put it on their own domain space and
so long as a partner has integrated with
orbitz era or if they have their own
solutions that have some kind of API or
some kind of scriptable deployment that
reseller can inherit those other
products from past diocese that have
integrated with us or build their own
solutions it's a completely self service
framework and this really helps you
enable your partner base accelerating
cloud sales is about streamlining
deployments streamlining access to
solutions through test drive and all of
this is with an eye towards automation
integrating with your existing CRM
system so that lead generation is
seamless so that your sales team can
help nurture these new leads and we can
actually notify you in real time when a
new lead has access to your test drive
you can call them before the environment
has has completed in terms of optimizing
operations this is really about
automation if you have an API we can
work with you if you don't have an API
we can refer you to a pudgy and then we
can work with you just getting we can
work with different kinds of partner
solutions
well not necessarily API driven we have
some partners who have you know are just
nascent ly entering the cloud and we've
implemented work flows through automated
email notifications we've done this
through automated notifications as
different JSON endpoints are totally and
to end ap is where orbiter is a silent
partner in the background and through
our integrations with different clouds
we help satisfy your end users needs
because different cloud providers have
different features and functionalities
it's not a bad thing it's not a taboo
it's just reality and so your partner's
demand to be able to deploy and consume
different clouds orbit our orbit area
helps you enable that so now let's talk
a little bit about Apogee Apogee is an
API management platform that really
helps streamline the end-to-end digital
value chain one of the guiding
principles of Apogee is they have a very
opinionated view of what api's can and
should be specifically it's not
sufficient to simply simply look at
things from the back end out you can't
slap api's on top of everything and
expect to have a unified user experience
where the user on the far left of this
slide is being considered from day one
so or Apogee likes to think of things
both from an inside out as well as an
outside in perspective because it's not
just a matter of making sure that your
devs are building api's you need to
rationalize out all those api's make
sure your different dev teams are using
the same kind of language and through
that Apogee can be the polyglot that
does all the translations between your
different teams wraps all these together
scales secures and helps monetize these
different kinds of automated systems
that you're enabling
so the apogee platform or Apogee edge
can be seen in many different angles
whether you're the app user you're the
operational team monitoring and
administering the backend whether you're
the developers or the API team trying to
bring that develop solution to your apps
into your systems so here are some of
the principles of apogee that you see on
the right hand of this slide apogee is
absolutely a purpose-built cloud native
API management platform with that
centralized point of government fully
multi-tenant support just like orbit era
apogee is a truly multi cloud platform
that can be installed in multiple cloud
environments and even on Prem again much
like orbit era they take a self service
standpoint because the last thing a
partner needs when they need nimbleness
and responsiveness is to file a ticket
with their platform to actually have
make something happen but we want to put
the tools in your hands and obviously
it's about scaling to enterprise an
apogee has helped many enterprises
deliver their applications their
services to millions and millions of
users here's some of the flavor behind
Apogee deep integrations with multiple
cloud environments as you can see here
Apogee while fully owned an integrated
with Google cloud platform has also
installed their application in multiple
other environments AWS on Azure through
cloud foundry on gcp in coover Nettie's
environments as well and you can install
Apogee in an on-premise to help bridge
that gap between the reality of today
where you're not quite yet on the cloud
and the future where you want to get to
so how do these two platforms fit
together orbitz era is a platform that
helps you monetize bill demonstrate and
distribute your products your solutions
products can be bundles of multiple apps
or single apps and we help you create
ecosystems and Link partnerships
together so if you're a distributor you
can invite your ifv partners to publish
their products into your distributor
ecosystem or if you're an isv that wants
to enable that you just need to
integrate with our systems and you can
use us as a force multiplier apogee is
API management at scale that allows
connections between different user
experiences different end systems and if
you've ever done a cloud migration you
know that it's real it can be painful
and onerous trying to herd the cats of
all your different api's apogee makes
that process relatively painless when
you combine these two platforms together
or vitara can act as the unified front
end with billing management partner
management ecosystem management tools as
well as all of the reporting and
analytics that you might need while
Apogee provides the automated unified
management portal that orbit era can
speak with and scale all of their
underlying systems to accelerate your
go-to-market activity so let's go
through a few hypothetical examples and
then we'll talk about a real life
example with pitney bowes this is one
example of how Apogee and orbit era can
help enable isv multi-cloud distribution
in the top you see where vitara the
visible portion to your end users is
that white labeled e-commerce store but
it's powered by our billing management
engine
customer management tools that allow for
customer specific pricing or even
account specific pricing we can enable
test drives on multiple cloud platforms
and integrate with multiple catalogs
across those different clouds Apogee and
meanwhile helps provide that unified
layer that allows for a single call into
apogee to speak to many underlying
systems so here as an example we can
help apogee unify payments erp
accounting and orchestration Apogee
secures it scales it and provides a
unified API front orbit Eric and then
consume consumption information from
Apogee and send orchestration calls
purchase calls credit calls into the
ISPs underlying systems another
potential use case is to create an app
ecosystem so because we're batara
interfaces with multiple cloud
environments and can orchestrate through
essentially an arbitrary API call we can
enable an ecosystem like this where the
applications are driven off of an orbit
era powered marketplace billing catalog
management as well as partner management
by the way and customer management is
tooled through the backend of orbit era
and allows the store to surface either
first party apps third party apps or
bundled solutions that call into
multiple of these and then the apogee
edge API management platform again helps
us interface with all of those myriad
internal ifc systems
so now we'll go into the actual pitney
bowes use case demo so orbit era apogee
pitney bowes as well as google have been
collaborating on a project to help
enable different kinds of distribution
and device construction and
manufacturing and distribution by the
part of pitney bowes this requires a lot
of work on the Android team on the
device side of things orbit era in the
marketplace app management and partner
management side of things and then
Apogee making sure that all these
systems both third and first party speak
to one another in a seamless scalable
way specifically we're collaborating to
create an android-powered device that
helps modernize and streamline the
pitney bowes shipping label machine and
turns it into just a shipping label
machine or a strong market leading
shipping label machine I should say to a
digital distribution platform where they
can not only fulfill their goal of
making shipping easy but also use it as
a monetization platform for preacher
distribution so if you look at this
diagram I want to first draw your
attention to the right hand slide the
apogee powered payment api's Apogee
provides this unified management layer
where they have a billing account API
payment transaction API different kinds
of reconciliation reporting AP is that
orbit Eric can call into on any product
purchase so once a product is purchased
off of this orbit air-powered app
marketplace we can integrate with Apogee
with pitney bowes systems to instantly
validate whether they can purchase this
or not checking their ledger account
will create that transaction in the ERP
system instantly as well and establish
the billing
relationship all on the click of x or
vitara in the middle helps talk to the
android-powered device as well as a
pudgy and provides a partner portal
through which pitney bowes partners can
create their own apps and solutions can
then be distributed to these millions
and millions of small business devices
this includes a robust set of governance
and approvals so that pitney bowes
admins have complete control over what's
published and where then we have the
android-powered device on the left-hand
side we've been collaborating closely
with the Android team to create a
customized device that sits on top of
this shipping label machine that can
then be used by these small businesses
to purchase new products and services
things like G suite for the small
business right through the shipping
label machine then orbiter itself
enables a myriad of pricing models
within this ecosystem you can pay by the
SIP you can pay by the drink you can pay
by the seat pay for it by the week month
year fortnight too if you want you
define the frequencies and all of this
is then integrated with a seamless user
experience because we need to have the
user experience in mind each and every
step of the way and very importantly as
pitney looks towards the future orbit
era because of our multi-cloud axis or
view of the world allows us to then
replicate this marketplace onto multiple
devices not necessarily just Android
devices can include windows can include
web other mobile devices as well so now
I'm going to go through and actually
show you a live demo
of the pitney bowes orbit or a use case
and we'll actually first start with the
tablet so this is an example of a real
live tablet that would be sitting on top
of a device think of it like your modern
copier here on the screen we have the
orbit era store as well as a couple apps
that i purchased beforehand given that
ass live demo so a user can click on the
store and see a consumer-driven
experience they see bundled solutions
here's an example of three applications
to first party pitney bowes created apps
send pro and the location intelligence
my pro adam as well as a third-party app
should brush now we're logged in as a
user and i can browse these solutions we
make it easy for the marketplace owner
to populate different kinds of marketing
content you can then allow your users to
choose from multiple payment options for
the same based product and we can change
the orchestration or parameterize any of
the user choices here to inform how the
product is actually deployed i'll go
ahead and choose a small business option
here and then we get back to a regular
consumer driven shopping experience
shopping cart like people are used to
everyone in an enterprise is a consumer
in their personal life so they like this
kind of approach here we have purchase
orders which are automatically
synchronized with the api or apogee
powered payment platform house within
pitney bowes so this is now after we
click checkout validating that the
customer has enough money in their
ledger account to validate this purchase
after we check out the purchase is
confirmed and now orbit era sends the
signal out to the mobile device
that it now has this application if I
now go back in I can click on my new
send pro product send pro is now
interfacing with a pudgy powered api's
we have plenty of money in our account I
need to send some so I'll choose one of
my pre existing contacts I'll decide
which package I want to buy as the
internet catches up I'll choose the flat
rate box and remember this is sitting on
top of an actual printing device so once
I confirm this purchase I'm ready to
print click that green button voila
ready to ship except now pitney bowes
has enabled themselves to add new
products and services over time invite
partners to deploy their products and
solutions into this marketplace that's
already embedded in over 1.4 million
small businesses globally now let's
pivot and look at the actual laptop
where I'm logged into the apogee
management platform here's the apogee
dashboard looking at the actual activity
underlining these apps total
transparency into all activity within
the ecosystem product managers love this
dashboard because it lets them know
exactly who has been using which app and
for how much whether they're
experiencing any errors or not real-time
visibility into end user experiences we
can actually look at some of the API
proxies that are being called underneath
this live demo I'll look at for example
the shipping API
here I'll look at the shipping shipment
API and as you can see here it says
which environments this set of api's has
been deployed into and what the
underlying calls are being made within
the various internal pitney bowes
systems to enable this end-to-end
workflow so this platform now means that
pitney bowes no longer just sells or or
is simply using this device to fulfill
its primary mission of shipping labels
it's now a distribution platform a
digital cloud distribution platform
where they can add any kind of fast
service first party applications they
develop internally or third party
applications that they want to bring
into their ecosystem and we can then
replicate this process across multiple
devices in the future whether they're
android or not so you then have a
unified partner portal two onboard
different kinds of apps and solutions
through the orbital platform and you can
scale these operations seamlessly
through Apogee so I'd like to now
transition back to the slides and I'm
going to invite several of my colleagues
up on stage now where we'll have a bit
of a panel discussion and we'll also
have the opportunity to get questions
from all of you before we do that brief
review of everything that we've
discussed today getting into the cloud
requires a pivot from legacy
distribution which requires thinking
about internal systems as well as
distribution mechanisms in the future
and multi-cloud is the name of the day
from enterprise consumers Apogee edge is
an intelligent API management platform
helps to handle billions upon billions
of API calls daily
which helps partners scale their
business or vitara meanwhile helps
partners monetize bill demonstrate and
distribute their cloud-based solutions
SAS platforms and virtually any product
they want in to channel into their own
ecosystem or into partner ecosystems and
combined Apogee and orbit area together
can help make cloud transformations much
quicker and less painful
[Music]
[Music]